I've always been a pretty big cash  Dapper I always have a lot of liquidity  I just feel better with it people like  you're not getting the return I was like  dude I make a ton of money I also have  Layla and so she handles a ton of stuff  internally if I didn't have Layla and I  was trying to live the most passive  Chill Lifestyle I'd probably just put  everything into a dividend ETF makes  three four percent a year and still gets  the appreciation that's just truly zero  management passive income qualified  dividends for anyone who's curious gets  taxed at capital gains rates which are  lower but for me though I am going to  take bigger risks with the wealth I have  because that's the kind of the next  level of the game for me taking big bets